nein nein was mache ich denn jetzt ich
wollte einfach 20 zentimeter weiter
rechts und dann ist er perfekt gewesen
[Musik]
guten morgen herr hätte was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich bin eben aufgestellt und ich
weiß es ist kam jetzt schon länger kein
video mehr hat muss ich mich natürlich
auch ein bisschen für entschuldigen ich
war im urlaub und habe es doch einfach
nicht geschafft musste auch noch viele
andere sachen machen andere weiter
gesagt eine anderweitige sachen aber
heute gibt es wieder 1 und ich muss dazu
sagen es wird auf jeden fall interessant
er die heutige video die kommen nicht
von mir das ganze gibt's schon in
amerika als ich habe zum ersten mal
gesehen habt ihr aber gedacht hey das
ist echt cool und könnte wirklich lustig
werden deswegen habe ich das einfach mal
ganz stumpf kopiert wird natürlich jetzt
auch nicht eins zu eins
die idee dahinter ist einfach dass man
einem dartpfeil wirft auf einem web und
auf dieser map sind halt verschiedene
aufgaben von steckt und ich habe mir
gedacht und es einfach auszuprobieren
machen wir das mit restaurants für die
die jetzt immer noch nicht verstanden
haben worum es gehen wird ihr werden das
verstehen
ich habe gestern mindestens zwei stunden
damit verbracht sondern dumme karte
daran zu bringen ich war in sämtlichen
verschiedenen läden ich will gar nicht
lange lagern ich zeige euch einfach mal
ein paar ausschnitte
dann geht es auch schon los und dann
wird sofort ist gleich der erste tat
feld geworfen denn es geht frühstücken
ich hoffe dass das frühstück wird es
kann auch was anderes werden ihr werdet
verstehen da bin ich mir sicher
und ich hoffe ihr habt spaß beim zusehen
also heute viel spaß mit diesem blog ist
dass wir eigentlich so leute und zwar
habe ich folgendes vorbereitet um dieses
ganze projekt durchzuführen ich beim
einkaufen nicht mal im baumarkt ich war
bei irgendeinem da tobt und ich war weil
irgendwann denkt man landkarten kaufen
kann und ich war noch im copyshop weil
wir haben hier einfach keinen druck
deswegen gehe ich immer dass im copyshop
im baumarkt habe ich einmal hier diese
pinnwand und das brett gekauft das
irgendwie halb schrott ist die pinnwand
kommt jetzt einfach auf das bett damit
wir das irgendwo hinstellen können und
die da teile keinen schaden in dieser
wunderschönen wohnung anrichten weil es
ist neubau und ja wir wollen hier nicht
unnötig irgendwas kaputt machen hier die
landkarte die kommt er einfach mit
diesem kleber an die pinnwand und dann
erkläre ich wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
wie in der schule früher leute ich bin
so dumm
ich hätte mir irgendwie denken können
dass du ein ganz normaler geschick
stimmt nicht hält was war nur der
einzelne nicht noch hatte deswegen gehen
jetzt einkaufen und kaufen was
vernünftiges sechseinhalb stunden später
[Musik]
also ich würde sagen war jetzt erst mal
kurz dann sollte das ganze schön
getrocknet sein und auch nicht mehr
abgehen hoffen dass marx ich habe
nämlich noch dieses kribbeln besorgt und
habe hier auch schon mal die ganzen
globus ausgeschnitten
[Musik]
okay leute nach gefühlten ewigkeit und
mal wieder der fünf jahre zeit ist
eigentlich dafür eingeplant habe haben
wir diese karte wert der erste kleber
hat nicht gehalten bin ich los gegangen
wollten neuen kleber kaufen
sekundenkleber der auch nicht hält diese
pinnwand die hält einfach nicht bin ich
wieder losgegangen habe klebeband
gekauft panzer tape und jetzt hält das
ding ich habe auch schon alles mögliche
angebracht das heißt wir sind jetzt
fertig und ich zeige es euch mal kurz
hier haben wir die landkarte mit allen
verschiedenen fastfood logos oder halt
so essens franchise mäßige sachen die es
hier in köln gibt ich hatte es
eigentlich ursprünglich so geplant dass
ich genau einmal die ketten wer jetzt
zum beispiel mehr girls aus den usa
kommt wäre das in den usa platziert
werden
ik aus schweden kommt jetzt in schweden
platziert das ding ist nur das ist
einfach extrem viel aus amerika kommt
und ich wollte so ein bisschen halt die
ganze welt karte abdecken
deswegen haben wir jetzt von mcdonald's
über dunkin donuts über cave sie über
vapiano pizza hut taco bell eigentlich
alles so gut es geht verteilt und mir
hier haben wir drei da teile die ich
einfach umsonst bekommen hab ich war
heute in so einem daad laden da gab es
eigentlich nur so profi feier für 70
euro ich habe dann gesagt ich brauche
einen fall hauptsache das ding kann
fliegen und dann hat er gesagt passt auf
ich schenke dir diese drei anfänger
pfeile
danke an das shop cologne oder so jetzt
ganz wichtig damit die challenge sind
mal alle marken sind mit diesen japan
nadeln an gewinnen das heißt dieser
funktion wenn der fall jetzt zum
beispiel hier landet wird geschaut
welche panel von welchem restaurant ist
am nächsten einem dartpfeil dran es wäre
in diesem fall dann wahrscheinlich eher
oder fritten hören das ist auf jeden
fall jetzt schon mal finden dann nach
oben da oder ich sage einfach mal
keine ahnung 8000 likes wenn ihr bock
habt auch noch eine folge vielleicht
dann irgendwas anderes und ja ich kriege
noch besucht die tage also die dürfen
auf jeden fall auch mal werfen und das
ding ist fertig ich würde sagen
letztlich fest wie schnell die haare
gemacht hier habe die map ihr habt ja
schon gesehen
das ganze habe ich gestern schon
aufgenommen ich habe auch schon ein paar
grobe würfel gemacht einfach und zu
schauen ja auch deshalb gut hält und ob
die pfeile auf gut darin halten und sie
tun es deswegen ziehen jetzt diesem fall
wieder raus es geht erst mal frühstücken
wir haben jetzt halb zehn oder so alles
gibt ja einige anbieter dort die auch
frühstück anbieten dunking download
starbucks da gibt es eigentlich immer
was zum frühstücken mcdonald's und
burger king hat auch frühstück subway
habe ich keine ahnung ikea müsste auch
frühstück haben von dem ganzen rest habe
ich halt überhaupt keine ahnung hier
kommt jetzt schnell eine markierung hin
das heißt wir werfen jetzt immer ab hier
auf die karte auch ihr erster versuch
jetzt kommt es darauf an ich könnte
natürlich da auf amerika gehen ich
könnte aber auch auf australien gehen
weil wir da dunkin' donuts und star wars
haben oder einfach blind und lasst euch
überraschen ich die auf australien
okay aber wir haben ja auch dreieinhalb
meter entfernung ich weiß nicht ob man
das auf der kamera so gut sieht okay 3 2
1 okay das war ja gar nicht mal so
schlecht wenn man sich das jetzt so
anschaut ist natürlich schwierig zu
sagen
starbucks oder dunkin donuts natürlich
eher weniger gesund deswegen muss ich
das jetzt mal kurz abmessen leute mir
das jetzt glaubt noch nicht wir haben
einfach bei beidem 10 cm
ich konnte es nicht sagen ob da noch
millimeter unterschied liegt also
entweder ich werde nochmal das können
wir
mit den beiden aussuchen ich würde
einfach mal sagen jetzt zum anfang weil
es gleich wirklich noch viel schwieriger
wird wenn man mal schaut wie krass die
anderen sachen alle zusammen liegen
dementsprechend kann ich mir jetzt schon
fahren irgendwas da von außen also ich
finds lustig muss auch wirklich schnell
was frühstücken weil ich habe noch eine
menge vor
und ja also ich bin jetzt in der stadt
und geben so einen dummen parkhaus und
das mega erfüllt ich habe seit 15
minuten jetzt hier gefüllten parkplatz
gesucht ergänzt zu starbucks glaube ich
so daher beides ungefähr gleich weit
voneinander entfernt war habe ich mir
einfach mal bei eis geholt wo wir haben
ja einmal diesen halte das feld fast
auseinander
das bloggen und gleichzeitig noch
irgendwelche sachen transportieren ist
manchmal gar nicht so leicht
deswegen konnte ich es gar nicht so viel
film aber ist ja auch egal ich war auf
jeden fall bei starbucks dann hat mir
diesen cappuccino geholt für fünf euro
ein schnäppchen und starbucks wir
einfach dunkin' donuts und da ich genau
die mitte getroffen habe habe ich mir
gedacht falls du das einfach ein paar
donuts irgendwie konnte man nur sechs
holen eigentlich viel zu viel ich wollte
so 3 aber sechs wunderbare donau hat
nämlich alle anlächeln bei dunkin'
donuts da ich vorher auch noch nie
es geht erst mal nach hause und der tag
startet gesund
ich kann mich heute jung okay leute wir
kommen zum nächsten wurf ja das
mittagessen steht an ich habe auch
wirklich echt hunger wir gehen wieder zu
unserer wundervollen markierung hier
zurück die ich eigentlich nicht so
optimal platziert hat weil mir direkt
das so versteht aber egal ich hoffe dass
ich nicht die wand riffe wir haben hier
die drei pfeile ein nämlich und ich
würde sagen ich gehe jetzt mal auf die
ecke da oben rechts so um russland china
um da haben wir einmal dritten werk ich
her mit pepper ihr könnt auch gerne
kommentieren ob überhaupt alle leben
davon
ich habe ja eigentlich noch gar nicht
alle gesagt wir haben die burger king
mcdonalds taco bell safway pizza cave
sie kennt wahrscheinlich jeder dann
haben wir nordsee gut das sollte man
kennen ikea sollte man auch canon
bürgerlich das ist einem schnitzel laden
hier in köln ha ha ha kleiner mit seinem
online nächsten bürgerladen der mir sehr
lecker geschmeckt feld ich sehr lecker
findet wollte ich sagen fritten werk ist
glaube ich nicht so bekannt mit pepper
weiß ich auch nicht dank intonation
fabiano kennt auch jeder gut also
willkommen zum nächsten versuch
wie schon gesagt ich gehe auf russland
okay an ein ja so viel zum thema schöne
am neubau linken da profi das war voll
daneben
nein nein das mache ich denn jetzt
schaut euch an der pfeil ist einfach
direkt an nordsee ich hasse fisch ich
habe hier aber die nordsee direkt in der
nordsee platziert ich wollte einfach 20
zentimeter weiter rechts und alles
perfekt gewesen naja was bleibt uns
anderes übrig auf zur nordsee also auf
geht's zur nordsee
mir ist eben aufgefallen ich war dann
wieder ist mir eben also bewusst
geworden
einfach weil ich nicht gerne fisch esse
ich bin zwar schon mir kraft an so einem
ding vorbei gelaufen habe aber dort noch
nie was bestellt deswegen bin ich auf
jeden fall mal umso gespannter hat und
wir machen das natürlich für dieses
video metzger ich hab hunger ich bin
jetzt gerade auf dem weg dahin schon an
ein mcdonald und zwei burger kings
vorbeigefahren aber wir müssen auch fünf
kilometer weiter fahren
also werde ich einfach burger king
gebeten
geworfen einig wer ist irgendwie besser
gewesen und ich werde mir zu hause so
ich musste jetzt extra in so einem haus
gekommen weil es sonst nirgendwo nordsee
gibt kann ich noch ein bisschen shoppen
so leute ja ich war jetzt hier einkaufen
wenn jetzt wieder da und hab diese
wunderschöne box gekommen
er riecht auf jeden fall schon mal sehr
nach fisch hier im auto obwohl das ding
gerade mal zehn sekunden hier drin ist
ich habe mich hier für die fish and
chips box entschieden
eigentlich alter ich dachte eigentlich
dass werden jetzt garnelen drin aber es
ist anscheinend irgendwas anderes für
stäbchen oder so aber das wichtigste
waren eigentlich die pommes weil ich die
mag das ganze zusammen mit der kohle
sechs euro 30 gekostet also an sich ganz
in ordnung wobei es hier einfach nur
bitte lasst mich mögen schmeckt gegen
wie 0 nach fisch also ich bin eigentlich
überrascht hätte ich mir schlimmer
vorgestellt
naja jetzt habe ich auch mal 19 pro bier
genießt jetzt hier bei meinen essen wir
auch schon 16 uhr also ich bin ein
bisschen spät dran liegt zurzeit daran
weil ich abends immer noch was für die
uni schreiben muss und ich kann es
irgendwie abends besser deswegen gehe
ich immer wenn der nächste rat
vorgeworfen diese so leute
jetzt geht's gleich noch abendessen am
besten special guest und zwar wirklich
den pfeil
also ich war ja eben bei nordsee und als
nächstes das erste tor zu treffen
aber ganz wichtig pass auf dass du bitte
nicht gegen die wand wird weil den
hammern problem
ok ok wartet 32
zweieinhalb 10 5 und 0
ja ich kenne kann ich jetzt nicht
anfangen aber dazu leute also eigentlich
wäre jetzt aber wir haben schon nach 8
uhr das heißt er hat zu nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein wir wollen
jetzt hier mal nichts überstürzen guck
mal
wir haben hier eine kleinere distanz als
zur piano weil es wenn auch weil es
zählt immer von der nadeln ich kann das
auch sehr gern für euch gleich nochmal
abmessen mit einem lineal aber ich bin
mir sicher dass casey ist herbstmesse es
gleich ab und an aber es ist ok
ich habs grad mal ausgemessen von dem
punkt bist du cap sie waren es 10 cm bis
zur piano 13 das heißt es geht gleich
noch zu casey war ich auch schon länger
nicht mehr und man muss sagen ziemlich
ungesund dann bis jetzt heute das ganze
aber war mir irgendwie auch klar
deswegen geht jetzt noch schnell laufen
hier mit der neuen klamotten von provo
kann man auch mega entspannt zum joggen
anziehen
ja also wir sehen uns gleich so ich bin
jetzt hier bei krebs i hab grad überlegt
ob ich reingehe aber ist hier nicht rein
weil irgendwie komme ich mir also
dumpfer wenn man allein hessen geht was
nehmen würden
ich werbe das einzige was mir schmeckt
ist hot wings ja schon gesagt ich war
eben hier und krautsalat für mich auch
lecker so eine sache muss ich mal sagen
nicht richtig stumpf finden und zwar
verstehe ich nicht warum man eineinhalb
stunden bevor der laden schließt die
eismaschine seubert ich meine halbe
stunde davor ok aber was ist mit den
ganzen leuten die noch ein eis holen
wenn ihr das stehen habe dass ihr eis
verkauft dann könnt ihr doch nicht
eineinhalb stunden fast zwei stunden
bevor der laden schließt sagen das gibt
es nicht mehr
die eismaschine wird bereits gereinigt
trotzdem sehr netter mann am schalter
hier
wenn das auf jeden fall wieder zurück
habe hier meinen essen im gepäck und
hätte eigentlich lieber was anderes
denn hier immer noch fleißig an
hausarbeit schreiben ich weiß nicht so
wenig wie eine facharbeit für die schule
vielleicht habt ihr das ja schon mal
gemacht was ich habe irgendwie das
gefühl das video ist jetzt schon mega
lang also ich habe am morgen als ich
denke immer so zehn minuten ist okay
aber 15 minuten 20 minuten kommen sicher
die wenigsten glaube ich ganz anderen
zehn minuten reicht ja dann auch dann
kannst du schon so oft werden wie du
willst weder wahlrecht mieter also gute
nacht ja was geht nächster tag und ich
bin hier gerade am schnitt ich habe
eigentlich jetzt soweit alles fertig
geschnitten und das video geht jetzt
schon 15 minuten hier kann man ungefähr
sehen sehr erotischer gesichtsausdruck
an dieser stelle und ich habe ja eben
schon gesagt dass ich ungerne so 20
minuten mache ich kann jetzt noch
nachlegen aber es reicht auch erstmal
das werde ich erst mal wieder nen
schönen salat reingezogen
trotzdem wenn die bürger auf noch ein
paar ich meine ich habe ja die dart band
fertig gestellt da kann man ja auch
einiges mit anfangen dann lasst auf
jeden fall jetzt schon mal einen fetten
daumen nach oben oder was heißt hier
sind ja schon meine minute 16
und wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
gibt es ein neues video april nicht
vergessen bin ich ja sogar passende
checks natural instagram und yahoo 32